#HASHTAGWARS.
( APPLAUSE )
WELL, JAYZ STARTS HIS TOUR
TODAY WITH HIS WIFE, BEY ONCE.
BECAUSE NOTHING IS MORE HARDCORE
THAN RIDING AROUND ON A BUS AND
PLAYING SHOWS WITH YOUR FAMILY.
SO IN HONOR OF JAY AND BEY'S
TOUR, TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#MAKEARAPPERSOFT.
SO EXAMPLES WOULD BE:
LIL WAYNE BRADY, OR
50 SCENT OF A WOMAN, OR
WILL I AM SONOMA.
I'M GOING TO PUT 50 SEONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GO.
STEVE BYRNE.
>> BUSTER NURSERY RHYMES.
>> YES, BUSTA NURSERY RHYMES,
POINTS. ROY WOOD JR.
>> TWO LIVE DINNER CRUISE
>> YES, POINTS. UH-HUH, OWEN.
SNOOP DOGGY DAYCARE.
>> YES, POINTS.
OWEN AGAIN.
OWEN IS DOMINATING THE BUZZER.
>> B.M.X..
>> YES, POINTS. (BLEEP)
GODDAMN IT!
OWEN IS SHUTTING EVERYONE OUT.
>> PHARELISH.
>> YES, POINTS.
STEVE BYRNE, YOU'RE IN.
>> 50 SENSITIVE.
>> YES, POINTS. EXCELLENT.
>> KID CUDDLE.
>> YES, KID CUDDLE. POINTS. ROY
WOOD JR.
>> U.T.I.
THAT EXPLANATION EVERYTHING.
STEVE BYRNE.
>> BONES HUGS AND HARMONY.
>> YES, GOOD POINTS. EXCELLENT.
ROY WOOD JR.
>> SOLJA BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF
AMERICA
>> YES, VERY NICE. SOFTER, BUT
VERY NICE.